what's up everybody welcome to LED live
today we're going to be talking about
demonic possession in the music industry
musics all about image so who is behind
the mask find out on this episode of LED
live welcome back guys first off we'd
like to thank our patreon donors without
you we could not do this show if you
would like to support this channel we
got a link down there you can become a
patreon and you get a lot of cool perks
you get early access and a lot of
behind-the-scenes and you get to just
get to know us behind the scenes and
what we're doing you know also we got a
lot of cool merchandise on our little
likes to do TV towards slash shop you
can actually buy DVDs and t-shirts and
that helps support us and you can wear
your witness a great way to start a
conversation about spiritual things but
we want to get into this topic Eric you
have some amazing presentations on this
type of stuff so I'm excited to see what
you're going to share with us about
possession in the entertainment industry
I am really excited about being here
today and I want to tell you upfront
that what I'm sharing I'm not sharing
just because I read it in a book and I
don't I'm not bragging about that but I
know about this because I was in bondage
I was under the influence and and the
control of spiritual forces that I
didn't even think existed I mean I had
no idea that they could literally get
inside of you and affect the way you
think and the way you feel and you tell
that story and the dragon revealed you
get that on little light Studios TV and
get a digital format on Vimeo and that's
a really interesting story I learned a
lot watching that what we're gonna share
today is gonna deal with we're gonna use
the music industry as as our primary
focus but we are gonna include some
things from Hollywood and we're also
going to include some things personal
that's our goal is that whatever we're
watching today will not just reach the
head because if it stops at the head
you're still lost right you can know
about the mark of the beast you can know
about this and Dad and the Illuminati at
all you can know all that junk but if it
doesn't reach your heart you're lost
like Nicodemus was and he was a
god-fearing man but he had never been
born again so what we're talking about
today is possession entertainment and
the temple of your heart it's here that
Christ wants to dwell I want to open
today's program with a short clip from
one of the most powerful movies about
Christ that have ever been released it
was called the Jesus film project the
people that put it together they have
mailed out millions of them for free
worldwide I mean I can't even tell you
how many languages it's available in but
I want you to see just the beginning of
the story of man in our fall into
darkness this continued until one day
Satan tempted the woman to eat the
forbidden fruit and she gave it to the
man who also had
[Applause]
in so doing mankind rebelled against God
and went their own way as a result of
this sin mankind was separated from God
and was thrown out of the Garden of Eden
but God still loved mankind it was never
his desire to be separate from those he
created yet how could God be holy and
the source of perfect justice if he did
not judge mankind for their sin that's
powerful that is powerful but you know
there's there's a question when you talk
about possession the entire New
Testament especially the Gospels it's
all through the Gospels where Jesus set
people free from evil spirits that
actually had found access to live inside
of them it wasn't just whispering in
your ear they had gained access to the
heart and one of the questions that came
to my mind was okay fine there's
possession why I mean what was the
devil's purpose I think that the body
was was you know being the temple of God
was was supposed to be the indwelling of
God in his creation you know I think
that's how God has set up all of his
creation and it is unnatural for the
devil to possess us it is not his place
he's not designed to do that and so you
know to have an evil spirit in you
that's not their true rightful place and
we give them that axis and that's what
he wants he says I will be like the Most
High he wants to pervert everything God
has whatever God wants to do he wants to
do it but he's gonna do it his own way
and he said that in heaven he was like I
can be just like you you know I don't
have to obey your law I don't have to be
obedient I can do what you can do watch
this and he always does it forcefully -
he's trying to force his way into your
life where gods like you know knocking
and hoping you'll answer the door you
know that's exactly
someone asked it maybe a philosophical
question you can cut this if you need to
but uh before the fall did man need to
be possessed yes why because there's no
life without God being in you it
actually says I am dead in my life is
hid with Christ in God and and we
actually were gonna we've got a we've
got a couple of statements that that
showed that from the very beginning when
man was created it was God's purpose to
be inside because when you disconnect
god it's like unplugging the light bulb
from the socket and this is funny
because you all have already went like
twenty slides yeah but that's good
listen to what the Lord tells us in
first Corinthians chapter three verse
sixteen through 17 he says what know ye
not that you are the temple of God and
that the Spirit of God dwells in you and
that's funny because you know the Bible
said don't grieve the Holy Spirit God
it's actually his spirit inside of us
convicting our conscience even for an
unbeliever it's God striving inside of
man to win back his freedom as a son and
daughter of God so it's like God is
saying don't let the enemy steal what
you have been given now here's one that
we just talked about Isaiah chapter 14
and reference to Daniel chapter 9 the
Lord says how art thou fallen from
heaven Oh Lucifer how art thou cut down
to the ground which did weaken the
nations the tribes of the earth for thou
hath said in thine heart I will ascend
into heaven I will exalt my throne above
the stars of God I will sit also upon
the Mount of the congregation in the
sides of the north
I will be like the Most High and what
what struck me was is that he says I
will sit upon the Mount of the
congregation in Daniel chapter 9 daniel
is shown and he says this Lord forgive
thy mountain and by people in thy city
which are called by thy name well when
you when you put those verses together
verse Daniel 9 verse 16 through 20 he
says Mountain City and people that are
called by your name that means they're
all equated as being the same the
mountain of God is yes it's a physical
mountain in heaven or the New Jerusalem
but it's us so Satan said I'm gonna be
like you I'm gonna reign in your temple
and people go well his temples up there
and he's like Jesus said something I
believe it was in Luke chapter 17 he
said don't you realize the kingdom of
God is inside you and the word Kingdom
is the place where you reign the Jews
were like the ancient Jews I'm not
saying all of them were bad because most
of the early disciples were Jewish but
the the unbelieving Jews were like we
want a king here a physical king but
they were not willing to let him come in
and reign inside another one is in
matthew chapter 24 jesus said when you
therefore shall see the abomination that
makes desolate when you see the
abomination that makes desolate spoken
by Daniel the prophet when you see this
abomination standing in the Holy Place
whoso readeth let him understand what is
being made desolate the temple of God do
you remember in when the Jews had left
Babylon and they went back in Ezra
Nehemiah and they were rebuilding the
temple no fire came down from God out of
heaven and filled the temple like it did
in Solomon's day when Moses erected the
sanctuary hmm and the old men they were
upset because they were like yeah we got
a structure but there's no fire
we've got a form of Christianity a form
of godliness we don't have the power of
God and Timothy says that and I think
its 1st Timothy 3:16 he says great is
the mystery of godliness God manifest in
the flesh Christ in us is to hope the
assurance of that glory we lost when
Adam fell so Christ was telling us when
you see this and I believe he's telling
us the whole world is going to be
possessed before Christ returns either
filled with the Spirit of God or filled
with every hateful and unclean and evil
spirit Revelation chapter 18 and that
story I don't know if you're gonna bring
that up but that story is really
illustrated in the the example that
Jesus was talking about the man that he
cast out the demon out of the man's mind
and the demon came back and checked on
the man and he had swept up his house
but he didn't fill it with anything any
man he went back out and he got seven
more unclean spirits somebody came back
he was worse off than he was before that
just that just illustrates that we are
empty vessels so like you said we're
either filled with the Holy Spirit or if
you're empty Satan's not going to ask
for permission to come into your mind
he's gonna come in it so you need to
fill it with the Spirit of God otherwise
you could be full of unclean things so
like make desolate like make your mind
desolate make his temple desolate yeah
it makes me think of like the yoga you
know empty or am i right yeah yeah you
think of yeah you can I mean that really
brings the whole Eastern philosophy to
like that's that's a crazy deception Wow
you know you know what a lot of people
like when I grew up you know in a
Christian home I thought possession is
like what you saw in the movies yeah you
know you've my head spinning around you
know a couple of times I'm vomiting I've
got tattoos bad ones all over my head
and I've got ya I'm cutting myself but
Jesus actually said when he when he had
those twelve disciples when they first
came to him he said have I not chosen
you twelve and yet one of you is or has
a
devil and I couldn't even tell which one
is it who is it I know well I mean Peter
comes up to him and he's like get behind
me Satan you know and it's just like
wouldn't you be like you know yeah yeah
make a note of that because that's
something we don't see that type of
activity here in the US I mean maybe in
extreme cases people see demonic
possession but in third-world countries
or other countries I should say they
experienced it a lot did you notice that
ever in Indonesia hear about it I don't
say I've never experienced it but I've
seen some kind of this traditional thing
going on and they have to be possessed
to do it wait you just told us about a
doll that would like a latch onto
somebody or something what was that
about yeah there's this thing that they
do so they play it's like a game before
we play yeah but we do it we have like a
doll in the middle and we'll attach a
pen here and then the paper and then you
use some chanting and then somehow
sometimes the the doll get possessed and
I think I'm moving right so then you say
like jumps on somebody's back or
something yeah in some cases I've heard
a story that the devil got mad and just
latched onto somebody's bag like the
person feels heavy in the bag yeah yeah
I mean I've heard crazy stories like
especially from the mission field where
where you physically see this I remember
when my my brother he went down to the
whole mess that happened in Haiti right
and the earthquakes and you know a lot
of people they're all into voodoo and so
you know their country's destroyed their
half their loved ones are buried and
they're sitting there doing voodoo all
night long and he said it was the most
eerie thing ever and people just weaken
out you know we're just not used to
seeing that like that you know it's it
seems like something from the movies and
you know what's weird we have probably
more or as much possessions as they do
only the devil hides behind the mask
would you say that's because we are
considered a Krrish
nation if we saw it more like this
people would run into the church rather
than a wave of Jersey yeah you know I
think I think just the the I don't know
maybe the underlying I mean there's a
lot of Christian ideas that are American
II taught Christianity as a child and
then you experience these scary things
you're gonna run to God but these people
that are like growing up on voodoo and
stuff they probably like they probably
welcome that spirit oh I got the
Kundalini or whatever you know right
right right
do you know something that's interesting
though is it's like what I found in my
life the Bible says of holy angels that
says are they not all ministering
spirits sent forth to minister unto us
that are heirs of salvation
so if holy angels or spirits fallen
angels are also spirits the word angel
literally means messenger what is a
messenger bring the message new words
yeah God gets into us he dwells inside
of us through his word Satan gets into
us through words everywhere you go today
this if it's McDonald's if it's Hardee's
if it's the grocery store if it's the
elevator if it's everywhere you're here
I guess you're hearing Satan's music
he's you're listening to his songs all
day we're watching his words on
television we're reading his words in
the books and magazines and just because
you read something the first time it
doesn't mean it gives an evil spirit
access to come into you but they're
whispering and they're whispering until
they can get the door open wide enough
where you've yielded so many times that
they go he's mine I'm going in now and
once they come in they do not want to
come out it's really you said you're
listening to the devil's music you're
seeing it all this stuff anything well
that's kind of like you're kind of
that's kind of an assumption but in
reality Christian literature Christian
television Christian music is a minority
in our world you got like two channels
to choose from or whatever
you know you got one little section of
Christianity so you're right yeah that's
the world it's Satan's music that's
being pumped out there everywhere yeah
oh it's just an alarming to me I don't
know if you're gonna bring this up but
like when I heard John
Todd's testimony on you know the 70s
that guy that worked for Capitol Records
and you know he was specifically going
up into the the top realm of the Capitol
building and they would pray over every
single album attaching spirits to go
with those albums I remember a comment
that he made that really stuck in my
head you want to know how many demons
you have in your home go count your
records and that literally is how many
demons you have access to so we've got
to ask ourselves that now if if the if
the wicked people say hey we just made
this great album by whoever right we are
consecrating this to you we're giving
this to you Satan as an offering we're
asking for your spirits to accompany
every one of these that go into a home
shouldn't we be doing the same thing man
a lot of times we as Christians it's
almost like we're playing a game we're
playing Church we don't really believe
that Lord I'm praying over this whole
box of Bibles or this literature or
they're dbm say your angel to be with
every person that receives it and
believe it because if you believe that
God will do it yeah ever since I heard
that from John Todd we actually do pray
over our videos and you know we'll just
say you know please go and win many
souls of this but don't know who's gonna
watch this down they know so hopefully I
can I can picture that the the Angels
flying over the USPS amen amen
and it goes to the wrong house but it's
actually there right actually totally
happened Wow no Mike there was there was
examples where we would send DVDs to
people and maybe he would do the
shipping one day and I would do the
shipping one day and we'd send two boxes
to the same house then we get this
message like you know I needed two cents
because they had this other person give
this to others just a random thing that
we actually just missed you know and
both send it out so it's cool amen
I'm gonna read a short quote to you this
is probably my favorite book
outside of the Bible it's a book called
the desire of Ages on the life of Christ
if you've never read it pick it up and
read the first five chapters and you
will not be able to put it down listen
to what it says on page 161 from eternal
ages it was God's purpose that every
created being from the bright and holy
serif or angels to man should be a
temple for the indwelling of the Creator
from the beginning but because of sin
humanity ceased to be a temple for God
darkened and defiled by evil the heart
of man no longer revealed the glory of
the Divine one do you know the Bible
tells us that as a man thinketh in his
heart so is he as you think in your
heart if I've hidden God's Word in my
heart what does that do to your physical
your flesh what it changes things
Amen it's funny because I was just I've
been talking to it somebody that watches
the show and I've been you know just
answering questions and stuff and then I
mentioned that I mentioned some of my
old past life like doing rap shows and
stuff and they were just like what I
can't even picture that I'm like that's
weird because like I I lived it so for
me it I'm the other way like I can't
believe I'm sitting here in a ministry
doing some for God when that's the way I
used to be but people who only see me on
this show or like what you were a rapper
so yeah it changes you I have an insider
you changes your whole desires and I
think that's beautiful how people can
actually look at you now and be like I
can't picture that you know what I mean
like yeah I too can remember a time that
it was like I could never picture this
yeah you know and then all of a sudden
it's like yeah now we're here with a
bunch of Bibles and you're talking about
you know the deep thin is the best life
I've ever had yeah saying Joey I like
that you know back to what we saw in the
beginning Aidan's fall this shocked me
do you know that the Bible tells us in
Luke chapter 3 it's giving the lineage
of Jesus and it goes from Jesus all the
way back to Adam and you read through
someone so baguettes so and so and
Abraham begat Isaac and and it goes
backwards and you get to the very last
verse and it says an Adam was the son of
God not the same as Jesus because Jesus
was not created Adam was created but God
still said you're my son and and for me
I'm like what was it like when Adam woke
up after being created I mean like he
opened his eyes for the first time and
you're like and he was grown he was he
was grown he wasn't a little baby but he
opened his eyes what do you think he
asked and in jesus knew he's looking at
him and he's so excited
what and Adam the voice and Jesus goes
you're my son you are a son of God yeah
that's a weird thought to think about
like the first words what the word does
the first word spoken and you know
what's weird that was the first sin they
did not believe what God had told God
said you're my son Eve you're my
daughter Satan said you're not really
like God but if you will eat what I'm
giving you my words then you'll be like
God and they doubted God can they listen
to the words of the enemy and that's how
possession happens across the board if
if you have a chance also look up Psalm
chapter 82 verse 5 through 6 and I don't
want anybody to think I'm being
fanatical but do you know what it says
there and Jesus quotes this in John
chapter 10 in Psalm 82 verse 5 and 6 God
asked his people in Psalms he says have
I not called you gods and are you not
all sons and daughters or children of
the Most High it doesn't mean we're God
but it means we are like God we are
created in His image and he's like
what's wrong with you but you that
you're believing these lies of the enemy
Colossians chapter 3:16 in John 6:63
it shows us that God does dwell inside
of us through his word and I never
understood that it's like why do I have
to obey this
well he says let the word of Christ
dwell richly or abundantly in you for
the words I speak unto you they are
spirit and they are life so it's like
when I read this and me personally I
read it out loud I never used to until
God sent me free from my past now I
don't read the Bible silently I mean I
can't name less than five times in the
last 12 years over it it silently I mean
you read it out loud but I read it out
loud and the reason why is is because
when you speak it you're hearing it and
faith cometh by hearing so I had found
I'm not saying you have to but I have
found that it has enriched it has made
my faith really grow I like just making
the demons hear it yeah you know yeah it
does make a difference it's not just
mechanical words printed on a page when
you read it God's Spirit is actually
speaking to you and when you choose to
obey it
God's Spirit goes into you and empowers
you to will and to do what he's asked
and that's beautiful jesus said in John
6:63 it's the spirit that quickeneth it
means gives life the flesh profits
nothing people ask me sometimes about
the martial arts and they're like well
what if I'm doing this and we're not
bowing and we're not meditating I'm like
you're training the flesh it's worthless
it's gonna perish why waste the time on
trying to build something that's gonna
be destroyed spend that time here
doesn't mean don't exercise but it means
spend the time where the life comes from
this one really hit me in in the book of
James the Apostle James tells us that
just like the body without the Spirit is
dead so faith without works is dead and
that hit me a body without a spirit
that's us without God there were people
walking around Jesus all
time and he said let the dead bury their
dead they're dead in trespasses and sins
it's like they've got a battery in Jesus
like the battery's already run out I
mean they're just there on those last
few seconds of you know so it's like
we've got a responsibility to do
everything we can to win every person
that we can while they're still life in
Romans chapter 6 verse 16 it tells us
don't you realize that to whom you yield
yourself as a servant to obey his
servants ye are to whom you obey whether
of sin unto death or of obedience unto
righteousness and life so by yielding we
actually allow either Christ or the
enemy to take the throne
yeah either way people always go ah you
know you just sold out
oh you're selling out to one of the
others you matter he liked you pretty
much are yeah III think it's just very
interesting that the devil he claims his
ways are freedom yet really the freedom
comes through his ways our bondage
that's right and that's so funny you
said that the next slide we've got a
picture here of Rolling Stone magazine
and it's got a picture of Bob Dylan on
it who is one of the you know
old time rock and roll legends and Bob
Dylan actually has a song and it's
called you gotta serve somebody and I'm
just gonna share with you some of the
just a couple of those lyrics you may be
an ambassador to England or France you
may like to gamble you might like to
dance you may be the heavyweight
champion of the world you may be a
socialite with a long string of pearls
but you're gonna have to serve somebody
yes indeed you're gonna have to serve
somebody it may be the devil or it may
be the Lord but you're gonna have to
serve somebody
and you go this this guy was an old-time
you know rock and roll and he's telling
it yeah interesting that he chose you
know the devil or the Lord like those
are the only two choices which is really
either light or darkness there is no
gray hey ray and we're gonna we're gonna
get into some of this with the music now
there was a place that was renowned I
think it was highway 61 and was at 49 it
was called the crossroads in Mississippi
and it was legend that people that
wanted to make a deal with the devil
would go down there and wait at the
crossroads until the devil showed up so
if you were there the devil was like
well they want me now we know that same
thing with us if I go down and I'll rent
that movie from Netflix or I'll bring
that record album or that book into my
home the devil is like well they want me
here they invited me in they stepped
onto enchanted grounds like an
invocation like those yoga poses you
know yes exactly right but you know the
irony too is like you give up basically
or to make this deal the back end of the
deal is you got to give me your life
right yeah but you make a deal with
Christ and it's like you got to give me
your life and then I give you this over
here amen so it's it's it's either way
you look at it or cut it one's gonna be
a short term of fun one's gonna be an
everlasting joy Keith what was it that
Moses said about that about choosing
rather to suffer with the people of God
rather than enjoy the pleasures of sin
for a season yeah so like you said it's
like the devil will give you 70 maybe 90
years a pleasure
boom and you're gone that's it Christ
says give me those 70 to 90 years and
I'll bless you yes you're gonna have
some hard times but I'll give you
victory and then also on top of that
I'll also give you a life forever
[Applause]
[Music]
I understand you and why the devil's
doing that why he's making it yeah why
is he why is he making it public what he
did this is my this is my personal
opinion I may be wrong but my uncle told
me something one time he said God laid
out the rules for the great controversy
god plays by the rules and the devil has
to play by the rules God said I will do
nothing except I'll reveal my secrets to
to the prophets interesting and you know
what unborn again people will go I can't
understand it
well because you have to have God's
Spirit spiritual things are spiritually
discerned and you know what the devil
goes I'll play by those rules I'm
telling you in the media and Hollywood
in the music and I'm telling you what
I'm gonna do I'm sorry you couldn't
understand it you didn't have my spirit
yeah the sad thing is like people hear
this over and over and over you show it
to me like that's all I met afore so I'm
like they just don't accept it even
though it's right out there in the open
hmm what I had begun to wonder because
people told me when I was in the martial
arts and all the Eastern mysticism they
warned me this is not of God and is
right there in front of me and I could
not see it people like you didn't want
to I'm like no I literally you could
tell me there's a white dog right there
and I'm like I can't see the dog it's
barking its licking my I can't feel it I
can't see it right there
the god of this world has blinded them
amen yeah I mean it's amazing to me that
you can have like a series like the
Marvel series that is the most-watched
movie series in the world and they're
literally telling you the other side of
the of the great controversy it's
describing a battle literally of cosmic
proportions and then people just go it's
fake yeah but they're literally it mean
it's like creating this but sharing it
with the other side no it's weird though
is this we can all see that because
because they're spending time in here
yeah there's a time we couldn't see it
see Detroit this is the man that
originally wrote the song the crossroads
his name was Robert Johnson he was born
in 1911 only lived in 1938
but you can watch videos about him and
in his story they've got interviews with
people that knew him and they said he
was just he would go to these old juke
joints where the african-american people
often would would gather to drink or
stuff because there was still a lot of
segregation and he would play blues and
they said he would almost get run out of
the place because he was not that good
that's terrible yeah and the people that
knew him said that he left one night
apparently had been you know made fun of
or whatever nobody wanted to listen to
him play and he left and he went to the
crossroads and he came back it was just
a couple of months later and they said
they had never seen people be able to do
what he was able to do in that amount of
time hmm they said he was doing things
that it took years for now to do in just
a couple of months and and he went off
the charts but I mean look how long he
lived I mean he was like 26 7 yeah what
he died of
you know I don't know I'll have to look
that up this is another song that he
wrote and I didn't realize he had this
many songs about evil forces listen to
what he said early this morning when you
knocked upon my door early this morning
oh when you knocked upon my door and I
said hello Satan he said I believe it's
time to go me and the devil was walking
side by side me and the devil was
walking side by side then he says I'm
going to beat my woman until I get
satisfied so you know what the evil
spirit was doing inside of his mind she
said his woman you don't see why that I
will dog her around now baby you know
you ain't doing me right now she said
you don't see why ho that I would dog
her around it must have been that
evil spirits so deep down in the ground
the ground of the heart you may bury my
body down by the highway side baby I
don't care where you bury my body when
I'm dead and gone you may bury my body
ho down by the highway side so my old
evil spirit can get a Greyhound bus and
ride no he's right yeah it's like you
know it's just crazy doesn't matter
where I go and I'm dead and I'm gone you
know he knows he's full of evil spirits
I know I know now we're gonna show a
couple of more clips from some different
musicians we're trying to lay a
groundwork and sometimes like when I'm
invited to speak to young people or at
churches they're always like oh yeah
it's the kids that terrible music the
kids are listening to so I'm showing you
some stuff that you used to listen to
you know back in the 60s and the 70s in
the 80s it's not just the young people
today it's all of us the next artists
that we're going to look at is a man
named Jimi Hendrix
[Music]
and what I want to reveal to you is and
you can do your own research I don't
want to quote everything he said but
everyone that saw him admitted he's
possessed there's there's something else
working inside of him this is an
interview that he did with Life magazine
in 1969 listen to what he said he said I
can explain everything better through
music we hypnotize people as to the
rhythm and through the the music the the
type of sounds that you're hearing and
when you get them at their weakest point
you can preach into their subconscious
what we want to say and he's saying we
and that could mean the spirits that are
influencing them but it also could be we
as musicians right you use the rhythm to
hypnotize them you use the music to
hypnotize them and once you get them
just like a hypnotist you know when that
door has been open hmm then you can
preach to them what you want to say so
the words matter and the music matters
this makes me think of the number to
watch the video on our page that you did
there was at the Oscars didn't they say
something like that I said it's a it's
like preaching a sermon yeah you're an
example i I've always kind of begun to
look at media as like no different than
you would a sermon because what you're
getting from a piece of media is really
a worldview yeah how you should order
your life how your relationship should
be you know what you should dress like
all those things are things that you're
getting told out of the media but then
the Bible also is giving you that same
kind of thing how to order your life
what your relationships should look like
and you know so you're getting
information but it's just like where's
the source where is this coming
one from the dark side and one on the
light side now I'm gonna give you
another example I can remember my mom
and ill and probably some of you out
there or your parents will say oh I
don't listen to all those crazy people
like Jimi Hendrix and you know the doors
and or ac/dc or you know whoever Alice
Cooper uh you know Iron Maiden I don't
listen to that kind of you know bad
music what about Barry Manilow oh he was
a he was a good guy
that was pop that was not rocked Barry
Manilow and I'm not going to get into
his his personal orientation on life
right now but he did come out of the
closet a few years ago but let me show
you the lyrics to one of his songs it's
a song that every one of us have
probably heard the song is called
I sing the songs that make the whole
world sing let the lyrics come up there
so you can see them I've been alive
forever and I wrote the very first song
I put the words and the melodies
together I am music and I write the
songs I write the songs that make the
whole world sing I write the songs of
love and special things I write the
songs that make the young girls cry I
write the songs I write the songs my
home lies deep within you and I've got
my own place in your soul now when I
look out through your eyes I am young
again even though I'm very old oh my
music makes you dance and gives you
spirit to take a chance and I wrote some
rock and roll so you can move music
fills your heart well that's a fine
place to start it's from me
it's for you it's from you it's for me
it's a worldwide symphony I write the
songs that was Satan speaking
yeah through barry manilow and we don't
realize what I do now sometimes I'll
hear a song on the radio and it's like
all the words will come back in my mind
and I'm like what is that doing there in
God God's like Eric you set that in
front of your eyes and I'm like Lord I
repent for listening to those songs blot
them out erase those lyrics from my mind
in my heart because it changes us you
know what what's amazing is you you
think of these these are words right
help me hide your words in my heart that
I might not sin against you right digest
these words put them in your brain put
them in your mind so that when you do
come up with that confrontation that
you've got something to stand on and
this is the devil's version of that and
you know what's neat like I was never
good at memorizing Bible verses never
been good at it but I found that when I
read the Bible out loud I don't have to
memorize it I don't have to even try as
I'm reading it out loud God squirt his
spirit he's writing it on the tables of
your heart and I was like will you just
read it God will do it and he'll bring
it back when you need it I'm not saying
don't memorize but I'm like for those of
you that struggle in that area just this
is a good way to do it
The Rolling Stones how many people have
ever heard of the Rolling Stones
sometimes I look I look at people and I
mean you know I'm 51 but look at some of
these guys and they're like 70 75 80 and
they're still doing it they're still
acting like they're 20 year old you know
young people Michelle have you ever
heard of any of these people
I don't know rolling or so yeah but I
never heard their song praise God I mean
Hendrix no that's amazing so this is
definitely for our more mature audience
yeah well let me tell you this it
doesn't get better the farther down the
road we get now it's just like I mean
though Beyonce and what the other one
was I'm Nicki
yeah I mean you can get on YouTube and
just type in singers you know music
industry demons or spirits or possession
and bring up name after name after name
yeah don't watch those videos yeah watch
the ones from little like a an
explanation of them there's also a good
a good video from pastor Ivor Meyers
that really helped me it was called
sonic warfare oh man also escape from
the black hole those two videos really
really woke me up because you know even
though I may be older than 13 or 18 I
was listening to all the rock and roll I
mean when I was teaching martial arts I
went to church every Sabbath had family
worship and when I went to work we cut
the rock and roll on it motivated people
you know and had no idea that it was
getting inside my head and allowing the
enemy to preach to me 10 hours a day
mm-hmm anyway the Rolling Stones did a
song a number of years ago called
sympathy for the devil how many people
have ever heard of that and who would
want to have sympathy for them I have no
sympathy for them I've definitely heard
heard of the title someone I'm gonna
show you just a couple of things about
them before before we get there this is
one of their symbols that they've used
for years and years for their band the
tongue sticky now the the cover you're
looking at there it was their 50-year
anniversary I think album or something
but that has been on some of the old old
albums so when you see that tongue on
somebody's t-shirt that's what it
represents as a Rolling Stones and you
know I used to always wonder because you
see other people like Miley's Miley
Cyrus and who kiss gene Simmons gene
Simmons that's a good point I mean he
would always stick his tongue out but
now there's like girls like Miley Cyrus
she's not the only one though type in on
the internet tongue and you look at all
the people that are taking photographs
sticking their tongue out and I was like
why listen to what Isaiah 57 says draw
near hither ye sons of the
sorceress and ye seed or children of the
that's talking about Babylon 4
against whom do you sport yourselves
that's like going ah you can't touch me
it's sticking your tongue out going you
can't do anything you're mocking God he
said against whom make he a wide mouth
and draw out the tongue and you looking
forward draw out and it means to
protrude and stick out you know are ye
not children of transgression and
rebellion and a seed of falsehood mmm in
John chapter 8 do you know what God what
Jesus said he's told the Pharisees he
said you're all children of the devil of
your father the devil he was a liar from
the beginning
a murderer from the beginning and he's a
liar and the father of it and right here
in Isaiah he said the same thing that's
interesting I've never actually seen
that verse but I've seen like the Hindu
gods and stuff the Heather -
that'sthat's a good point I forgot about
that because a lot of the Hindu gods on
the the paintings and stuff they have on
the wall they're sticking their tongue
out and that's a symbol of mockery kind
of think of the serpent you know - like
at all the animals when you think of a
tongue that's like always coming out and
stuff now I'm that's a good I'm gonna
have to make note and I mean like that I
gotta remember the one with James
Simmons I gotta make note don't let me
forget that but I want to show you
something that I caught when I was
putting this together look at the tongue
look at the lips there's eyes yeah and
tiin eyes and teeth it's a frog oh yeah
interesting I mean do you see it I never
had noticed that before it's like if you
just yeah it's like you see it there's a
big yeah it clicks it's like there's his
head and there's the eyes and there's
the teeth and there's the tongue coming
out three unclean spirits like frogs
you know voices and words hmm like you
could put some legs under there and it's
a it's it's own thing now I'm going to
just show you just a short outline play
there
because it yeah it's messed up but I'm
gonna show you what they're doing and
let you look at the lyrics he says
please allow me to introduce myself I'm
a man of wealth and taste I've been
around for a long long year and stole
many a man's soul and faith I was around
when Jesus Christ had his moment of
doubt and pain I made quite sure that
Pilate washed his hands and sealed his
fate pleased to meet you
I hope you guessed my name that what's
puzzling you is the nature of my game
hmm just come right out with it yeah
that was just like the other song it was
Satan speaking through them stole many a
man's soul and faith I mean there's no I
know there's no happiness you know and I
mean these are old-school bands so it's
like you know we often look at the
modern media and we say wow man these
guys are bold that's pretty bold what's
scary is is if you type that song and
I'm not encouraging don't listen to this
music that's why I didn't play it I'm
reading it to you because it's me
speaking if I'd let him sing it you're
hearing Satan speak through him you
don't ever give the devil a microphone
mm-hmm because he lies he deceives the
the one thing above every other that
bothered me in that set of lyrics as
when he said I was around when Jesus
Christ had his moment of doubt and pain
Christ never one moment down no one
moment of his entire life did he doubt
hmm he said my God my God why have you
forsaken me and then he said
nevertheless into thy hands I commend he
he said God I've already made a covenant
with you even if you don't wake me up
I'll bear their sins and die for them
which is what we were talking about
earlier shudder at me shaken Abednego so
the same thing he's able to save us but
if you doesn't we're still gonna go on
the fire and it wasn't doubt they're
just like he might choose the lettuce
burn but that's okay you know
and I I completely forgot about that
would you find key I was just for some
reason I it seemed like Bob Dylan also
saying that song but he didn't but when
they are interviewed about it
they say that they wrote it like a Bob
Dylan song really because in my head I'm
like I remember that song and I'm
sitting there going
seems like Bob Dylan to me
did Bob Dylan sing that song so it has a
similar as above so you could feel the
spirit of the Bob Dylan spirit yes I'm
thinking Bob Dylan the whole time I'm
watching it and then when I look it up
it's like no Bob Dylan didn't do it but
he was they wrote it like a Bob Dylan
song you can find out multiple times
that's amazing news which is really
weird what I think is odd is I'm
familiar with that song I don't know a
lot of their music but I know that one
and and it's like you know people are
parents age are kind of just singing
this because you hear it like it's so
old now that you hear this guy stuff in
the grocery store so I'm you know mm-hmm
and and people can sing along with some
of the parts they know but then you read
this and they're like whoa it says that
like they don't like they're blended
like you said like it's saying it's so
clear that we're like they're not even
hiding it and yet people will still be
amazed seeing the lyrics even though
they know and sing the song and remember
the enemy is using this to get inside of
a person mm-hmm
and people go why I would never kill
anybody or I would never cut myself or
what maybe you're selfish do you know
that was what opened the door and Judas
is life he started off yielding over and
over again to a spirit an evil spirit of
selfishness until the point came he had
yielded so much that Satan it says
entered into him on the night of
Passover the Last Supper Satan himself
not just an evil spirit Lucifer you
entered into him a little more modern
we're gonna bring this a little bit
forward it's a good night baby my
teenage years that yeah a group that I
grew up with
it was called INXS and we're going to
show a little clip of this I hate to
show it because of the music but at the
same time I do need you to realize what
they're saying so rather than me reading
well I'm gonna read the lyrics and we'll
let you watch the little clip in one
section of the song the name of the song
was called devil inside mmm
you remember that and listen to what he
says here comes the woman with the look
the look in her eye raised on leather
it's talking about what she's wearing
you know with flesh on her mind words as
weapons sharper than knives what does
God say my word is like a two-edged
sword my word is spirit the sword is
two-edged cuz it will circumcise your
own heart and the other edges to cut the
chains that are holding somebody else
and he says that words are weapons
sharper than knives makes you wonder how
the other half the righteous half died
then he says here comes the man with the
look in his eye fed on nothing but full
of pride that's something pride that's a
demon full of pride look at them go look
at them kick makes you wonder how the
other half lived devil inside I'm just
going to show you just for a minute and
this is 80's stuff so those of you that
are you know Generation X or whatever it
is now you can laugh but it doesn't
matter it's just the same witchcraft
package for a new generation
[Music]
look it is I
but full of pride
[Music]
man I hate listening to it yeah cuz they
can get catchy but notice how like
you're saying these words that are sharp
as knives this is like seductress or
whatever but then it says he was fed on
nothing we're supposed to feed on the
Word of God but he was fed on nothing I
pull of Pride Lucifer is the the king of
Pride and the whole yeah the whole thing
is just like it's just straight telling
you yeah Jesus said the words I speak
are the bread that came down from heaven
you know Moses and the children of
Israel ate manna but I'm the real bread
the Word of God is the real bread and
when you eat it it gives you a life and
he asked the question he's he's fed with
nothing makes you wonder how the other
half live how can you even live without
the Wow it's like really like thanks
he's teaching at the Bible it's a group
called you too how many people out there
never heard of you too I've been told I
look like Bono by a couple I did I
enjoyed their music a lot a lot of
people have had the impression that they
were a form of Christian music and and
we're gonna show a few clips here in a
minute but listen to what what's amazing
lead singer Bono is called by many
modern pastors the emergent church
leader their spiritual icon the emerging
churches spiritual icon it's like
contemporary Christianity and when I say
contemporary I don't mean modern I'm
saying how they're changing Christianity
they're doing away with the foundation
of God's Word
they're introducing worldliness and it's
like you've got some really good juice
there but if you add five gallons of
water to it it's got no taste any more
than that that's what's happening in the
emerging Church I want to show you a
couple of things here from them the
first clip we're going to show is an old
clip where they're interviewing his
right-hand man that
remember his name if it was blade or
somebody but he was the the right hand
singer in the group and he's talking
about the fact when they're singing
these songs he said this one song in
particular is a gospel song that was his
words so we'll watch that clip
well we wrote the song I still haven't
found I'm looking for which is a gospel
song pretty much I mean we it doesn't
sound much like the gospel song the way
we do it but if you look at the lyric
the basic music that's exactly what it
is
[Music]
they were the first movies
[Applause]
[Music]
okay now after seeing that it's a gospel
song listen to what what this website
said three members of the band of you to
profess to be Christians and they have a
great influence in evangelicalism and
the emerging Church and contemporary
worship movement now listen to these
names Eugene Peterson the author of the
quote message Bible says that Bono is a
prophet like John the Baptist Oh think
about that for a minute I know like
people got hold the messages a good but
the guy that wrote it thinks John Bono
is a prophet like John the Baptist Brian
McLaren and Tony Campolo say that Bono
is moving the world toward the kingdom
of God that's terrifying because God
what they view the kingdom of God is is
everybody coming together and let's be
one you know put aside your differences
set aside the the doctrinal things let's
be one at all cost and that doesn't mean
just Baptist and Adventist and
Methodists and Lutheran's that means
Buddhists and Hindus and Taoist and
Islam and all religions a one-world
religion yeah music is powerful enough
to make that happen and you know the
Pope is even using that contemporary
Christian music at almost all of his
gatherings now because it has the rhythm
it unites all millions that come to see
him it unites them because it gets them
on that same rhythm listen to what he
goes on and says Bill Hybels pastor Bill
Hybels
interviewed Bono at Willow creeks
community churches leadership's
Leadership Summit in 2006 that's scary
and Rick Warren invited Bono to
Saddleback Church to help launch his
peace program I know that name that's
terrifying
so this is not one person and and you
know you can look this up online I found
the entire article with all the
references the references for where
these things happen it would have taken
another whole page just to include
so I didn't didn't do that hmm now I
want to I want to read to you the words
to one of their first most popular songs
that was called still haven't found what
I'm looking for
now listen they say they're Christian
they say this is a gospel song listen to
the words I have spoke with the tongue
of angels I have held the hand of a
devil
it was warm in the night I was cold as
stone but I still haven't found what I'm
looking for what bothers me is he says
I've spoke with the tongue of angels
that's what Paul said though I speak
with the tongue of angels and yet I have
not loved so he's saying I've been on
God's side I've also held the hand of
the devil and his hand was warming but I
still haven't found what I'm looking for
and then listen to what he says later on
in the song I believe in the kingdom
come then all the colors will bleed into
one unity bleed into one well yes I'm
still running and then he says you broke
the bonds and you loose the chains you
carried the cross of my shame of my
shame you know I believe it but I still
haven't found what I'm looking for
wow I can see why somebody would think
that's a gospel song because of the
carry the cross but when you see but I
still haven't found what I'm looking for
that should be a red flag right right
yeah you know it's funny when you when
you read the title of that the the
chorus ran in my head did I do that same
for you I'm gonna recognize it yeah I
almost like I almost like saying it out
and I was like wow that little tune in
that little frame were these lyrics in
my head surprising I did not know that
so yeah I you just remember the chorus
yeah having a lot yeah and it's like wow
you you've seen the cross but you still
haven't found what you're looking for
like you know what's weird to me is the
music was not hard rock it they not
heavy metal it was not threat it was
there was something in it that allergic
and we're gonna talk about that through
this series there are certain
frequencies of sound that caused the
body to release dopamine and other
hormones we don't realize that sound and
they know it so that means they can play
you can be watching I think of an
example have you ever been to church and
you were hearing a man or a woman
sharing God's Word in Sabbath school or
Sunday School and you're hearing God's
Word and you sense God's presence you
know he's talking to your heart have you
ever felt the chills run up the back of
your neck and you're like and you know
that's a confirmation of what you just
heard do you know that you can play
certain kinds of music it doesn't matter
what they're saying the same chills run
up your spine yeah it's because of the
it's because of the hormones and the
chemicals that are being released by the
human brain the devil said God designed
these things to happen to connect you to
him so I'll counterfeit it so that
you'll be connected to me we talked
about this on the yoga one was funny
that you're here again but can't
remember if it was Paul or linen one of
those guys from the Beatles that song
Krishna Krishna yes yes what he said he
said my sweet lord
yeah my sweet lord yeah I mean you
listen to that it sounds like so loving
and peaceful and my sweet lord and
you're like oh it's like a Christian
song and then he's saying Harry Krishna
and he said Krishna I wanted to to lull
people to sleep or whatever into a false
sense of security as what he said by
singing hallelujah my sweet lord and I
said once their foots tapping and
they're not in their head then I slip in
the harikrishna I forgot about that I
mean that's why this song was you know
if you said it's a light melody it's
talking about the cross but I'm still
haven't found what I'm looking so we see
every 10 words a word dis found in the
Bible we know it's got to be Christian
yeah but we've got it that's what the
devil does he can quote the Bible but he
takes it out of context there's always
these visual confirmations you know like
Bono is known
we're across oh yeah that's a good you
know things like that yeah but so do all
these other artists like pentagrams
behind it but they're like Ross we're
going to show another clip from you two
and this one is a newer clip and this
one is a little bit startling it's very
short but it's actually from the Rattle
and Hum album and they were at a live
concert and Bono is singing sympathy for
the devil oh he says I'm a Christian but
he's singing the Rolling Stone song
sympathy for the devil it's startling so
let me show that clip
[Music]
Wow that's crazy and that's pretty
telling you know it's like cuz yeah you
would never find anyone of us Christians
like literally just because the song is
cool I performing something like that
that's so against what we believe you
know I think it really speaks to the to
the heart of where he's coming from
you also can't have the Spirit of God in
you and do that I'll give you an example
I can remember when I first got into
trying to share the gospel after God was
pulling me out and he was God was still
fighting Christ was still fighting to
get me really free so I still had some
bondage in my life in sin and probably
influence for me little spirits you know
I would sit down to do a Bible study I
couldn't write it out it's like I would
I would write it's like I couldn't make
the pieces and God was like Eric do you
understand there's something that's
inside you that's not allowing you to do
that because it's going no you can't do
this for Christ because your mind can't
serve two masters that's right
so it's like we have to say I'm Yours
Christ and and through this program
through this series we're also gonna
have one series specifically on how do I
get free doesn't matter what it is the
answer is the same thing I mean like if
it's drugs if it's pornography if it's
you know rock and roll if it's Hollywood
it doesn't matter what it is there's one
answer and it's easy lay it all down at
the foot and believe he did what he
promised he did he's an all right we're
getting close here to to the conclusion
of our program I want to show you I want
to show you just a couple of Hollywood
examples this is a lady named Oprah
Winfrey I'm sure most of you our
audience is familiar with her listen to
what she said and these are two quotes
and we have them on the screen from two
different sources she said I asked God
for grace they were they were asking her
about how are you able to play in this
film the color purple which was her
groundbreaking film they said how were
you able to play such a powerful
character
she said I asked God for grace now
remember that word grace it doesn't mean
mercy alone
it means the influence upon my heart the
divine influence upon the heart so I
asked God for the divine influence and
the power of the spirits plural plural
notice that not the power of the Holy
Spirit of God spirit but of spirits and
she said calling on you calling on you I
really believe I can call her the spirit
of this dead person her and so many
others they were like how do you play in
this part and I remember Scotty and
Keith in you guys when you did in Mikey
when y'all put together that one on
channeling spirits and Denzel Washington
they asked him on 60 minutes the same
thing you know how did you play this
part he was like I went into a room got
down on my knees and I asked the spirits
to come in and they played the porch hmm
Time magazine interviewed her in 2001
and this is what they said Oprah calls
these her go there moments spiritual
episodes of divine guidance that far
transcend the chatty exchanges with her
studio audiences Oprah says that she has
come to know each of them personally
that's a familiar spirit you know it
personally and she calls them in at will
to guide her in her work
now that's best Time magazine that's not
some obscure thing she said you know
that's pretty scary and you can look
young you can look it up if they still
will let you if not I know you can order
the magazine it's almost like it's my
conscience and my devil all in one now
wait a minute your conscience is here
and if she says what could be my
conscience or my devil but they're both
coming from the same place inside and
you know what's interesting about that
is the truth of this is jesus prayed and
said that they may all be one as you and
my father are me and my father are one
you know that's interesting so God wants
to get back in us like he was in Christ
and be one amen
then she says it's almost like I can
read minds at this point call it
instinct or intuition or a sixth sense
that's like our gift as actors and
actresses now we'll step back just a
page Marilyn Monroe and I'm gonna make
this short listen to what she said
completely aware of her demonic
possession Monroe told a reporter that
there were others who resided and lived
inside of her she described it as Jekyll
and Hyde two and one
more than two she said I'm so many
people they shock me sometimes I was
like what Johnny Depp said you know or
yeah or Keanu Reeves or you know any of
those men and then listen to what she
said I wish it was just me the cost is
high there were interviews that were
done with or producer and with other
people that helped her and her acting
and there were career and they said when
the camera was off she was a completely
different person they said there was
nothing they even made you want to carry
on a conversation with her and they said
when she saw a camera
she changed instantly and you look at
this photograph of her and she doesn't
look happy there's no joy there's no
peace there's no assurance and then over
on the left is a picture of her when
they carried her out on a cot after they
found her dead she was born in 1926 and
she died in 1962 she was 30 36 short
life Wow Bruce Lee was what 33 years old
32 years old
no Keano not calories his son Brandon
was yeah 28 yeah the Bible says in
Revelation 18 Babylon is fallen she has
become the habitation of devils
the hold of every foul spirit in the
Bible you've got Jerusalem which
represents God's people Daniel 9 tells
us and you've got Babylon which
represents the Devils people and God
says they have she has become the
habitation of devils and a cage of every
unclean and hateful bird and then he
caused us today and says come out of her
my people and be not partakers of her
sins
do you know Paul talks about that he
said not only do my people do the same
things that they have pleasure in them
that do it it means I would never kill
anybody but I'll sit down and watch an
action film where 500 people get a shot
I'm enjoying I'm having pleasure
I would never commit adultery but on
that film there were three people that
were committing fornication and four
that were committed in adultery so we
watch it and we act like we're immune
even I think it's interesting it said
that that she's the cage of unclean
spirits and and she just said I wish it
was only me but I'm these multiple
people in me it's like a cage you know
she can't let them out hmm she can't
open the door yeah that's a good point
that is a good point when Jesus asked
what is your name Legion the house ins
you know it's like wow yeah a lot of
energy do you know what's weird though
if we take that to practical and let's
just name some common things selfishness
pride resentment bitterness anger hate
lust lying
I mean Nangal yeah I mean how easy would
it be for not saying somebody's
possessed but how easy would it be for
one person at your church to have 10
spirits that are in their life
influencing their thoughts and their
feelings and their emotions
that's scary it is he says be not
partakers of her sins so that you
receive not of her plagues for her sins
have reached unto heaven and God hath
remembered
our iniquities that strikes me because
you know what the promise is to us if we
have faith in Christ your sins and
iniquities will I remember no more they
don't have faith in Christ and gods like
their their sins are still written on
that book where's Eric's will they've
all been confessed well where are they
there's no record of them i blotted them
out with the blood of my son his life is
Eric's life hmm awesome
no man can cast out the evil the wrong
the wrong that have taken possession of
the heart only Christ can cleanse the
soul temple but he will not force an
entrance the devil was like a rapist you
know you're like knock on the door you
crack the door and boom he knocks the
door down and he won't let you know he's
in crisis not that way he knocks on the
door and he says hey can you talk for a
few minutes come out and let's talk on
the porch and he waits for you to invite
him to come in and he wants a bride he
doesn't want a one-night stand
Amen what's the eternal lifetime he
doesn't want a man that was
profound
he wants a bride not a one-night stand
well because you can't date Jesus yeah
that's right I mean otherwise you know
there's a and there's a bride
which one are you gonna get with he's
listening the other day to somebody he
was like why did Jesus come and Nate was
single because he had the church oh wow
right hmm he was engaged to the church
so I never thought of that so in that
sense he had a woman he wasn't a
relationship
yeah yeah when he said single or
something and so I wasn't thinking like
relational ya know I just that I've
never considered that I hadn't either
and he was faithful to that one bride oh
that's beautiful
only Christ can cleanse the soul temple
but he will not force an entrance today
he says behold I'm standing at the door
knocking If any man or
woman will hear my voice that means
opened the door to hear is not just I
had a man at church one time tell me he
said he was in the Navy and he said you
know when a superior officer would come
and give a command he said you would say
aye aye sir and I was like what does
that mean he said if you say aye
it means I've heard you I means I've
heard and I will obey and I was like
that's literally what it means in the
Navy and I was like that's what God's
asking the Lord is saying why do you
call me Lord or King and yet you won't
do the things that I say well don't you
trust me
he says I stand at the door and knock If
any man or woman will hear my word and
open the door I will come into you and
sup with you in you with me
Jesus will subdue our iniquities and
thou wilt cast all of our sins into the
depths of the sea his presence within
your heart will cleanse and sanctify the
soul so that you may be a holy temple
under the Lord and a habitation of God
through his spirit
God is ready to set us free and today is
the day there is no tomorrow because you
can't guarantee you're gonna wake up
tomorrow if you're at home right now you
hear God speaking to you you can hear
him speaking to you right now as he's
speaking to us go get on your knees and
open your heart to your Savior today and
he will come in and set you free
thank you all for having me it's been
such a blessing seeing everybody again
it's always good to have you all it was
good to see you guys again too and we
look forward to hearing from you please
write to us send us emails talk to us
through Facebook and keep us in prayer
all of us are human just like you we all
have battles but your prayers make the
difference if you pray in faith God will
answer hallelu see you guys next time
[Music]